foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
neither
the classical symptoms of Parkinson's
disease are capable
are accessed and the motor control
abnormalities although a substantial
body of State such focus on a central
nervous system which affects effects of
Parkinson disease the represents
understood about peripheral and
neuromuscular calculate
recently transistors
sequence among individuals with foreign
partn synthesis samples 12 samples will
add example 12 and just sample 12.
both voltages were wrong exercising this
is free control subjects the system
while skeletal muscles are a sequence
are approximately 60
000
920 transcript
this data set is very interesting
because it's not only compares the
disease Parkinson's disease patients
with normal control sample except this
comparison registration with control
samples data olashes and the control
samples that are young kids
understand
and focus specifically on those things
so far that are responsible for
Parkinson's disposition that's why I
choose this interesting data set the
data set we searched for analysis is a
normalized data set not this raw data
input server is a bioinformatics
platform that combines statistical
analysis models into pipeline details
with heterogeneous speed system it
enables faster and easier analysis
integration and visualization this
algorithm it is algorithm that is wave
interface foreign
31 417 transcript of
protein synthesis was olajide and 19047
concept of
protein synthesis versus Uranus and then
these values are then solved with
respect to P values values they've got
some significant number of reasons so
the data is like we got
15 under 17 significant differences in
case of pump inside this is
interest of partisans to process
generator currently we don't know which
are up regulator and which are down
capability and the further says they
will know which are application
now I will discuss the results
of the analysis
first I will discuss principal component
analysis of TCA in the dynamic study
reduction method that is often used to
reduce the dimensionality of the large
data set by transforming a large set of
air levels into a smaller one that's
still contains most of the information
will last week
where we can see that
this year has a quite height of it it
says add this is 1 and 2c2
Federal approximately takes place 50
percent of PC but despite that data
difference is dwellers and data points
are mixed with each others and so
according to our analysis the PCA
doesn't give up there but doesn't show
many results straight up separation
between two set of samples that is
different PD versus oaxes white
right
this one if it would do something that
would require to change but here it will
differentiate expression analysis the
thinking of understanding that is
might not be conducted on this data with
the linear approximately adding a
dimension reduction that PCA applies to
that data might not be reflected in the
separation between periodation and the
young middle letter
then we perform the effect of analysis
into method identify things that are
commonly expressed in the condition that
we had
within this commonly expression it
identifies the dispersion of the gene
a volcano plot is a type of slider plot
that shows statistical significance in
value versus magnitude of a change whole
value in the volcano plot all the black
dots which are
which we can see in this volcano plot
other ingredients which are not
significantly expressed
defective doesn't keep the list of a
background stream in blue below
those are the chains that are
significantly expressed but it doesn't
show any difference in the whole thing
or difference in the expiration level
but the expression quantity itself is
significantly higher or lower diverse
proteins or the rest which is either of
regulated or down regulations depends on
the Block to full set
and
we are interested in only religion we
are not interested in either black
scenes or by the
Solutions
the next analysis
if you and this pathway between ontology
and business analysis is a relatively
used for internal interpreting hyperbox
has to put molecular data and generating
hypothesis about underlying particular
phenomena of estimate common Pathways
between these two are
between these two comparisons are active
mediated cell contraction and muscles
kilometers sliding
and there is one more that is active
margin kilometers
there are quite a number of human
response Pathways that are activated not
data differentially exists analysis like
type 1 particles
number options related to 13 myosin
filament reduce in Old adult to United a
number of Genesis related to
active magnitude
self contestant reduces
independently Express number options
there is
quite the same number in both the cases
that is young adult and the whole level
the further you can see a lot of ion
channels Pathways which are suppressed
foreign
analysis
you can feel that the Transcendent
engineering reflector activity and the
response to bondings
are identified to be the most important
Pathways that are differentially
negativity is increased in Parkinson
disease versus genetic analysis there
are a lot more
Pathways or is that the activities which
are shown you but
these are the most important and highly
negatively expressed Pathways that's why
pathways
identified to be the most important
Pathways because
differently acceleration for both the
comparison that is uh Parkinson is
with one nice comparison to make some
salt off for biological interpretations
or that is set up this holy quality
change the amount of change that
we we are observing between the
expression of this so it is threshold is
more than one position then may not have
seen as of regulator and if it is less
than one portion then we will mark it as
the accountability
so here we can see the list of few
things in both the cases which are of
regulated and down regulated
I used to explain how to understand the
function of the property
in case of abbreviation
in previous
[Music]
without
of regulated and in both the cases we
found that the nine genes are common and
these are different languages which are
common in theory versus way and the
periodiversary survived
I'm talking about left hand side
portion which is the ninthians included
CR c r y and cd7
9A OPI device is
in case of dog resolution
then previously called
45 which are round regulated and in
Three Rivers this old adult we got 80
exchange which are not regulated through
in both the cases are
CST and even second one is m a t t l 21c
F turbine is that 10 to 40 and so on
in a regulation the Indians have
functions
that they have noticed are a motion
related to new lungs muscles contraction
and apocalsis
in down regulation the jails have
functions mostly related to
immense response and channels and neural
prolification
several concept of Interest identifying
this study if not it has on known
biological reduce the measure symbolic
pattern is very similar between young
adult and older whereas few of his you
know commenters
sometimes allow us to make an
observation on the current opportunity
that are essentially expressed presented
two comparisons and comparing there this
is set identify the network of seeing
that progress with this involved in
physiological process including
neurotransmitter mode
development such as regulations visiting
influence
potential
Department
foreign
so that we can get more specialization
that uh we have seen in the market
the present data allow us to only
speculate on observative direction of a
change more time more foreign
could be the result in the Old English
station for the research on the cancer
related field
could be performed
thank you so much for your time thank
you for listening to me thank you
goodbye